good morning John so last week I went to
the Monterey Bay Aquarium which is from
what I can tell one of the best places
on earth
I got amazed by mudskippers enchanted by
otters amused by mola mola and
dumbfounded by cuttlefish all of these
delights and more are on display for all
who attend but Monterey Bay Aquarium has
a secret first let's talk about Chicago
where in 1930 Shedd Aquarium opened at
that time it was the largest aquarium in
the world the only problem Chicago as
you may have noticed is really far away
from the ocean they solved this problem
by sending train tanker cars down to Key
West Florida filling them with seawater
and sending them back to Chicago now of
course we can make sea water from
scratch which is what they do at Shedd
Aquarium today but it's a pain you have
to buy huge amounts of something called
instant ocean that you mix in to fresh
water in like 80,000 gallon tanks and
it's expensive so you have to constantly
filter that water and reuse it aquariums
on coasts do not have this problem
because they get their seat water from
the sea and Monterey Bay Aquarium gets
its seawater from some of the best sea
in the whole
[Music]
if you take a look at the west coast of
the United States you'll seem after the
coast happens there's that little
light-colored bit that's the Continental
shelfs geologically that bit is part of
the Continental landmass it just happens
to be underwater but you also notice
just one place where there's a little
in the armor of the continental
shelf a place where the darker blue goes
all the way up to the coast that is
Monterey Bay specifically it's Monterey
Canyon which has cliff faces more than a
mile high and from shelf to base is
roughly the depth of the Grand Canyon
that Canyon gives researchers access to
an amazing variety of ocean depths and
thus ocean ecosystems without having to
travel far off shore Monterey Bay and
the area around it also has consistent
winds that push warmer less
nutrient-rich waters offshore cool clean
nutrient-rich water from deeper into the
ocean then rises to the surface in a
process called upwelling that makes this
area of the Pacific Coast extremely
abundant and it makes the water
fantastic and so the Monterey Bay
Aquarium simply pumps 2,000 gallons of
seawater permitted into its facility and
a roughly corresponding two thousand
gallons leaves headed back into the bay
the system that manages this is a marvel
and I got to walk around in it and learn
a little bit about how it works
[Music]
the scissor tracks over 33,000 data
points making different exhibits in
different temperatures for different
animals and ensuring that flow is never
interrupted for too long it's built to
handle massive earthquakes and has a
redundant backup for everything at the
Monterey Bay Aquarium not only are they
guaranteed a perfect match for the
chemistry of the sea they also have a
perfect match for the microbiome of the
sea which turns out to be a benefit to
the plants and animals that live there
just like we are in a healthy
relationship with most of the
microorganisms that live on and around
us the microbiome of the ocean keeps
plants and animals healthy the greater
the diversity of microscopic species the
less likely it is that harmful
infections will occur now this all
sounds very rosy so far but it turns out
building your whole aquarium around the
use of raw seawater opens up a whole
other set of engineering challenges the
biggest of which is probably barnacles
in your pipes now you might think like
just put like a barnacle resistant
coating on the inside of your pipes but
there is no such thing as a barnacle
resistant coating they can stick to
anything barnacle larvae are also tiny
too tiny to filter out of the source
without the filter constantly clogging
and you can't get the water moving fast
enough to keep them from cementing in
the pipes so you need two sets of pipes
so that several times per year you can
close one off at both ends starve it of
oxygen killing the barnacles and then
send a rubber plug called a pig through
the pipe to wash all the dead barnacles
into the sea
apparently this smells just fantastic at
the Monterey Bay Aquarium
they'll filter seawater to get the
biggest stuff out after the filtering
the water heads straight into their
Monterey Bay kelp forests
so the ecosystem of that tank is as
close as possible to the ecosystem of
the actual Monterey Bay from there it's
distributed throughout the rest of the
aquarium that tank serves as a kind of
public facing and storage so whenever
new water isn't coming in the level of
that kelp tank actually starts to drop
and for the exhibits that contain
wildlife native to Monterey Bay you
don't even need to filter that water on
the way out because all that stuff is
already stuff that's in the bay but
while an aquarium in like Atlanta
doesn't have to worry about introducing
invasive species because it's a pretty
long and arduous trip from Atlanta to an
ocean ecosystem the Monterey Bay
Aquarium discharges water just as often
as it comes in it's a constant cycle and
for their exotic exhibits they have to
filter water out and pass it through
what's basically a UV tanning bed which
sterilizes the water before it's
discharged to the bay so think about
that next time you're wondering if you
should go in for a tan and finally
anyone who's picked up a five gallon
bucket of water knows that water is not
light so pumping water requires a lot of
energy and if the intake gets clogged
like say by a smack of jellyfish the
giant steel cylinder that keeps big
animals from getting sucked in gets
crushed like a soda can and the water
stops flowing ocean water over the last
50 years or so has gotten warmer and
warm water holds less oxygen that's bad
for many animals but jellies which have
been roaming the world's oceans since
before fish even existed appear to be
taking up the slack so jelly fish blooms
are more common and these steel
cylinders need to be replaced more often
so nothing about this place is simple
but all of this hard work and
engineering in the basement creates this
magical experience for the millions of
people who visit here every year
every person who walks in these doors
encounters what in many ways feels like
another world that we just happen to
share this planet with that world in a
way walked right up and knocked on the
door of Monterey California and humans
answered this aquarium is that open door
giving us an appreciation for the oceans
and an understanding that this in fact
is all one planet and needs to be
treated as such
on the surface it looks like effortless
magic underneath we see the secret the
work the engineering the science the
passion and the geology and climate that
make it all possible
what a fantastic place
[Music]
thank you obviously so much to the
Monterey Bay Aquarium and all the very
cool people on the social media team
they're following them on Twitter or
Instagram is an absolute joy they are
some of the best in the world at science
social media so I put links to their
social in the description thank you to
Andrew Huang for the music in this video
all of the tracks were from his album TV
and video games and John I'll see you on
Tuesday